at Downing Street well quite a dorm is
very passionate about attacking the
gates claiming it is storming the police
there's a huge passion for Tommy what's
going on just now what do you think will
be the result of entity will the police
listen will the media listen will anyone
take notice of it today or Voris so much
just absolute passion evinced well we
weren't expecting quite a passionate
response we didn't call for anyone to
target the gates of the place but Big
Bang in there people are feeling
frustrated a man who's spoken up to the
people has been silenced that people
found their voice taken away and it's
understandable there be protests so you
must peacefully keep protesting
internally soon because if it's not him
their rest will be other people soon
they were solely silenced all Patriots
to protect the globalist elite and I
think what they're going to do is keep
doing this I don't think they're going
to let him out sadly and this is a
massive problem it's a slow decay of our
country's to become a police state in
the politicians best interest to pay
attention to what the public of doing
don't you
yeah I think this postponed the
reporting on the case which is rather
awkward because a suspended sentence
he's done it again
the notes for the first court case and I
do fear that's going to be a harsh
punishment so where's this censorship
coming from this lots of tinfoil hat
conspiracy theories Saudi Arabia are
buying us out they're funding this that
the next thing well that's not a tuna
for conspiracy it's sort of fact we have
a lot of money pumped into our country
by Wahhabist Saudi groups which are
radical Islam they're pretty much the
same as Isis they trade most of the
homes in our country the the summon
creatures who are all very radical
versions of Islam and that's why we have
a surgeon crime a surgeon terrorism
because a lot of extremism Wahhabism is
being pushed in this country and this is
funded by Saudi Arabia and there's
tolerated by our post modernist Liberal
government because they're making all
the money out of oil deals whether they
buy a lot of oil from somebody right
there there's also a lot of so it's a
two-way business still going on there
and they need to protect that so that's
why they're going to ignore all of these
horrific crimes that are going on at the
moment and what do you see the future of
this country carve a wall I'm sure you
won one area rule of law on the other do
you have a more optimistic future for
Britain imagine i feel greatly that this
country is going to end up as a whole
somewhat like what happened in Ulster
where you have two communities divided
by religion who didn't get along then
you had violence on the street but
people fighting on the street I fear
we're going to end up with large we
already have ethnic get around but
didn't Trevor Phillips as a of
that so basically is going to end up
increasing tension between those they'll
be increasing terror attacks and I fear
there's going to be increasing fat
clashes against those tension and
bloodshed on the street it's rather like
what a certain politician warned off
they will be rivers of blood and I just
hope that the governor will really clamp
down on terrorism to stop this but they
won't and that's why we as Patriots must
keep speaking up keeping outspoken on
these issues and force the government to
do something you need to elect in an
election somebody actually stands up the
people not the Tories because there
just lefties northern labour party none
of them are standing up for traditional
values
none of them are salvageable of law none
of them care about the people but we are
a nation ibly lazy voters
whereas immigrants are like a political
animals didn't know the importance of a
war so we invited them into Parliament
they're promised them they will get from
the block for us suppose we've seen a
lot of us and may has been appointed
around the country they work as a group
to get people who represent them was the
average English purse it doesn't seem to
care much about politics it's very
laid-back don't come together fight on
amongst each other rather than for me in
any kind of united movement and we will
lose the country if we continue acting
in this way it will become over one by
one Harbison and the last question is a
Burgess issue that we were becoming
inert to terrorism you know if lyric
beer wasn't bad enough
London Bridge the presence of rich you
know would it be enough rising what
would be the cutoff point were the or
demand will say enough we've seen so
much terror so much blood shares you
know it's becoming an ugly occurrence
the problem is most people today are so
heavily brainwashed by the lefty
propaganda through the universities and
the middle class does always dominate
the control the politics the
infrastructure of a country
they're so brainwashed that they're so
busy virtuous signaling even when people
are raped
they're not doing anything about it
there was I think was an oil Sweden a
major politician whose daughter was
raped and they were trying to excuse it
there was a politician that came out of
one of those Scandinavian countries
saying they had been raped and they felt
sorry for the perpetrator
so basically loss I have speak nothing
people wake these people up there so
brainwashed and thought but I believe
there was a silent majority in this
country we're starting to feel fed up it
is not going to take this any longer and
it's got our force you reach a boiling
point and I hope it doesn't because
be terrible bloodshed in the street and
who you voting for at the moment I
support you kit but I'm friendly to
people for better days and eventually
they will come together some kind of
coalition okay thank you so much